This idea that we should prefer
heavier flows brings us to
the scaling algorithm.
One idea is to find
the heaviest possible flow.
We could do this by starting with
an empty graph and then adding an edge
with the largest remaining residual
capacity until there was an ST path.
But this would be unnecessarily slow.
Instead, we fix a schedule of thresholds
for the residual capacity, and
lower the threshold when there
are no more augmenting paths
in the residual network.
We'll start by defining the residual
network with threshold delta
to include only those edges whose
capacities is at least delta.
Note that when delta is equal to 1,
this is the same as our traditional
definition for a residual network.
We can state the algorithm as follows.
We initialize the flow to 0 and
the parameter delta to be the largest
capacity coming out of the source.
This is a trivial upper bound on
the value of a single path flow.
Then while delta's at
least 1 we look for
an augmenting path in the residual
graph with threshold delta.
And we use this path
to augment the flow.
Once all such paths are exhausted,
we then, cut Delta in half.
And repeat.
Some of the analysis,
we can do just by inspection.
Letting C be the initial value for
Delta, it's clear that we only use, log
C iterations, of the outer loop, since
we're cutting Delta in half, each time.
And the steps of the innermost
loop here, finding a path and
using P to augment the path or
certainly order E.
The big question then is how many
iterations of the inner loop are there?